je vous posais des questions à vous de
me dire lequel des deux est le plus
comme ci ou comme ça lequel des deux
reports et répond le mois à vos messages
dd c'est flou c'est le flou le plein des
voix il répond tu si un jour après un
prime pour dire une grosse connerie sur
des conneries
s'ils sont d'accord tous les deux ans
les défis auxquels des deux fait le plus
attention à son look
flo chloé ça reste flou c'est flou la
dernière fois sur son instinct g il a
sorti une chemise à ses frais au net
c'est pas compliqué dit merci
alors vous dites
wes de la production on vient de
confectionner attention lequel des deux
est le plus bosseurs lequel des deux
travaillent le plus assez serré la d2
c'est serré les deux disent les deux
travaillent beaucoup quand même
jerbi trucs que les gens savent ou ne
savent pas sont pas au courant c'est
flou c'est les compos d instruire
ouais même à poser des d instruction mon
album de la musique sur les albums ça
c'est vrai moi j'ai envie de dire devant
tout le monde que c'est mon frère qui
est rassuré c'est vrai c'est vrai pour
s'apprêter à l'heure où tape dessus mais
quand même faut lui dire les gars c'est
blake est mais ce prénom qui parle de
moi là je suis comme un vase lequel des
deux a le plus de plus la cote avec les
meufs
loterie baratine il n'a même pas besoin
de faire ça y est tu voyais très flou
sur quoi et parce que il est marrant tu
vois et hall il est un peu plus tu le
connais un peu plus timide ouais c'est
ça la journée il avait divorcé petit
orifice n'était pas à m'écrire mais ça
mais pourquoi quelque chose à débattre à
faire lequel des deux est le plus radin
mon à bien les gars à mon avis vous
pouvez savoir un peu cette crise et qui
pour toi
j'arrive pas tu dirais qui vu la montée
de flou zicophonies ouais ouais ouais
ouais ouais ça les frères c'est un
malade
ah ouais c'est ça les gars mais c'est
pas économe et franchement tu vois tu
trouves tu es le plus radin j'ai pas
suffira d'un frère mais pas avec ses
potes et tout mais pour lui ferait il se
fait zéro plaisir c'est ça c'est vrai
georges chez lui la veille avait
quasiment pas un meuble pendant un an et
demi c'est pareil il s'assoit chez lui
il regardait pas un pc tout ce qu'il
fait je me contente de simplicité
l'amour